and a crackdown on climate protest
features in the queen's speech with
harsher sentences for those who disrupt
travel
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world hear from
the people being hardest hit by those
changes and reports on the race for
solutions so when cop 26 concluded its
president proudly boasted that the goal
of limiting global temperature rises to
1.5 percent had been kept alive but now
the met office is warning there's a 50
50 chance of that threshold being
exceeded within five years and as you
can see on our data dashboard the
average global temperature is closing in
on that 1.5 figure for all the details
on that story here's our climate change
correspondent hannah thomas peter
in india and pakistan a severe and
unrelenting heat wave has killed dozens
of people
this extreme heat just one consequence
of global warming
now our uk met office report suggests we
could be heating up even faster than
previously thought we should be
concerned this is
more evidence that climate change is
progressing that um
that the in the future is going to get
warmer
and that climatic streams are going to
get
worse so
i think you should be wearing we should
be um
trying to
think about how as a country we can make
contributions to cutting
greenhouse gases
the report predicts that over the next
five years the average global
temperature could be between 1.1 degrees
celsius where it is now and 1.7 degrees
higher than pre-industrial levels
and the chance of temperatures in at
least one of those years exceeding 1.5
degrees is now nearly 50 50.
on top of that there's over a 90 percent
chance of the average temperature for
the coming five years being higher than
the previous five
it makes the paris climate conference
where the ambition to try to limit
warming to 1.5 degrees was first agreed
on seemed like a long time ago
i do think it's still achievable but it
will take an effort like we've never
seen before from governments from
populations from citizens
it would be you know the greatest
challenge that mankind's ever faced to
try and completely turn the direction on
where our missions are heading to
rewrite the global economy so that it
actually delivers for the planet and not
for pollution it's going to be a
monumental challenge
climate change is a threat that has
loomed for decades now it is here
the effects felt not just in the global
south but all over the planet we may
still be wrestling with how to tackle it
but scientists have never been clearer
the window for meaningful action is
rapidly closing
hannah thomas peter sky news
and you can track global warming with
our live counters that use data from
leading climate change scientists as
well as the national grid on the sky
news
website well climate protesters that
glue or lock themselves to key transport
infrastructure could soon face harsher
prison sentences it's all part of the
government's plans to crack down on
protests set outs in the queen's speech
today but is there too much focus on
those demonstrating rather than the
wider issue our reporter aisha zahid is
here thanks so much for joining us good
to see you in the studio um first of all
just set out for us what those road
blocking climate change protesters can
expect
well this is really targeting those
groups groups like extinction rebellion
insulate britain and just stop oil and
it's all about uh combating those really
disruptive tactics that we've seen over
the last couple of months we've seen
insulate britain and just stop oil
they've blockaded bridges and roads
they've glued themselves to roads and
they've also paralyzed oil refineries
now this new legislation will mean that
first of all police have extended stop
and search powers and then on top of
that several other things will become
offenses
included in that is locking on so
locking on to people to objects to
buildings will become an offence
alongside obstruction of major transport
works things like hs2
and those two things will carry a
maximum prison sentence of up to six
months or an unlimited fine or
potentially both and then on top of that
any interference with interest
infrastructure things like airports
railways
that will also become an offense
carrying a maximum prison sentence of up
to 12 months potentially an unlimited
fine or again potentially both okay so
what has the opposition said or civil
liberties groups as well well it's been
criticized because this isn't the first
time we've seen these measures initially
the government brought them forward
whilst discussing the police crime
sentencing and courts bill that went to
the house of lords and that's where it
was knocked back it was deemed that
these measures were too they were
controversial so they were scrapped and
then later on that bill was passed so
the
chief executive of the group fair trials
it stands they campaign for fairness
equality and justice the chief executive
has said that reintroducing these
measures that were once scrapped uh goes
to show that the government's intent is
to what they say destroy the right to
peacefully protest rather than to
protect it so real concerns here over
freedom of expression and the right to
protest okay i sure thank you very much
for that um well let's take a look shall
we some of the days are the climate news
now because countries across southern
europe have been setting new records for
the amount of power generated from wind
and solar farms and figures from the
think tank ember show that those green
energy sources accounted for 40 percent
of spain's electricity last month while
it was over a quarter in italy greece
and portugal also set new records for
solar generation
sales of used cars electric cars have
reached new record highs and figures out
from the society of motor manufacturers
and traders showing more than 14 and a
half thousand battery electric cars were
purchased in the first three months of
this year now that's more than double
the total bought in the same period last
year
new figures from climate charity
possible has shown the aviation industry
missed all but one of over 50 climate
targets it set itself over a 20-year
period the research blamed a lack of
reporting and public accountability for
a failure to hit targets on energy
efficiency to save fuel and
on increasing sustainable fuels
well we talked earlier about the
threshold of 1.5 degrees potentially
being exceeded within five years but of
course that figure is just a global
average and some countries like india
and pakistan are already coping with
extreme temperatures in its latest
report the ipcc warned india will suffer
more frequent and intensive heat waves
as well as extreme rainfall events well
today it was 39 degrees in the
industrial city of kanpur um in india
and it could be as hot as 44 degrees by
friday while in jaipur temperatures
could reach 45 degrees celsius by the
end of the week
but what are governments in those
countries doing to alleviate the crisis
well joining me now is saruchi budwell
director at the energy and resources
institute in india and a lead author on
the ipcc
also thank you so much for joining us uh
suruchi can you tell me how hot it is
where you are and how you're coping
yeah so the temperature is away above 40
to 44 degrees centigrade uh
we are a country in the tropics and
normally
experience extreme temperatures during
the summer but what has been unusual for
us in this summer is that in the month
of march and april as soon as you know
like we had uh the winters basically
coming to a close in the spring season
approaching we had temperatures uh
spiraling and being way above the
normals that we are used to experience
in these two months and therefore as a
result we have the heat wave condition
that has gotten created in large parts
of the country
and what impacts is the heat waves
having so actually on on just normal
life i know it's devastating crops but
how are people managing to cope in these
extreme heats
yeah so ideally there are uh different
ways in which responses uh are
structured uh uh over the years the
government has set up an early warning
system where cities are basically uh
provided in advance a three to five day
forecast with regard to the kind of
temperatures that are likely to prevail
and therefore you know governments at
the sub-national scale space basically
could take some corrective steps to
assist people and help people in coping
with the situation uh they're simple
things in terms of basically providing
advisories to people in terms of staying
indoors uh avoiding outdoor labor during
peak hours and staggering work hours in
the morning and the evening of course it
does affect the productivity of people
and their contributions uh also in terms
of you know setting up public
places uh for provision of drinking
water to avoid dehydration and heat
strokes so there these are simple
measures basically that are being put in
place but of course there are advanced
measures that people are also being
advised to as do's and don'ts uh while
the rich may and people who have the
facilities and access to cooling devices
may be increasing the number of hours
for which they are running the devices
maybe it was 8 hours and 10 hours before
but it's 12 to 14 hours and 16 hours now
that people are basically in their
houses running these the air
conditioning units to help them cope
with the situation but the poor and the
vulnerable who do not have access to
these devices possibly looking at ad-hoc
measures in terms of basically using
gunny bats you know wet gunny bags as
you know a cooling means uh of air
passing through their doors and windows
desperate desperate situation
and you paint that picture uh quite
strongly how do you think
india needs to adapt and how soon do you
think that change needs to happen
so i do feel that
we have to have global goals set in
terms of containing the rate at which
the changes in the climate are basically
happening
uh you did mention about the 1.5 degrees
c commitment uh linked to uh the
discussions in paris and definitely
that's
that's a an
unachievable goal frankly speaking
because we're already 1.5 degrees into
the change itself and we're still
experiencing the changes and
and of course uh you know we may pass
the 1.5 degree goal but uh but possibly
i think we need global collective action
uh which at least contains the globe uh
two or two degrees centigrade and below
world so that the impacts uh that we are
likely to face in the next coming
decades whether it's india or any other
region in the world in the form of any
other extreme like floods cyclones
tornadoes storms uh while we are hit by
a heat wave in the central and the
western parts of india the eastern part
of india is going to experience a
cyclone incidence so uh so we are you
know doubly basically exposed right now
biocyclone on one hand and with the heat
wave condition on the other so i think
we need to basically have collective
action to be able to contain the rate at
which the climate is basically changing
contain the rate of emissions that are
being contributed to the atmosphere and
increase in the greenhouse gas
concentrations so that
you know these forms of extremes can be
limited we will be into some degree of
change with regard to the climate
because we've already committed the
world to that change but i think the
extremity of it no things to worsen than
where we are today uh that is something
where we should be focusing as as a
world and nations have to come together
to be able to give that global
commitment okay so she thank you very
much for uh your insight there um more
to come on that story i'm sure in the
next few days uh well do stay with us
coming up
i'll be joined with economist vicky
price and climate columnist for the
independent donor mccarthy will be
discussing the warning from the met
office about a 50 50 chance of exteeding
a global warming threshold and how spain
and italy are hitting new records with
renewable energy
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
independent united kingdom
[Applause]
these last few years have seen some huge
stories
[Music]
and these stories have been driven by
politics by politicians the people in
power
you must stay at home and it's my job to
figure out how these decisions made by
politicians
impact all of us in our everyday lives
this is the worst thing i've ever been
through in my life people turn up here
with their child stuff in a black sack
and just say i don't want them and that
is what it is it's first class poverty
is this an example of the welfare state
failing
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
these are stories that affect us all
millions of children are now having to
catch up
some stories
have changed all of our lives because
like the residents the staff are being
infected
politicians they make decisions all of
the time and it's our job to hold them
to account i wonder if you will take
this opportunity to apologize to those
families but in the end the real power
doesn't actually lie with the
politicians
the real power
lies with the people
i'm nick martin i'm the people and
politics correspondent at sky news
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news um we're
getting straight into discussing the
issues of the day with economist vicki
price and climate columnist for the
independent donor mccarthy hello bo
thank you so much for joining us this
evening um so our first big topic then a
new report from the met office says
there's now that 50 50 chance will
exceed the key
1.5 degree threshold for global warming
and that's within the next five years uh
donica i'll start with you how worried
are you by that
well it's very clear now that what the
government said after cop was untrue
we haven't saved a chance of avoiding
1.5 degree rise
that means that that is now guaranteed
to happen and what we are now facing is
a desperate battle not just to save two
degrees but we're heading fast through
three degrees
what we're actually now witnessing with
the terrible stories across the globe of
south india pakistan
is unfolding the greatest act of
ecoterrorism in human history and we're
still failing to tackle or even begin to
reduce our emissions we're in code red
as the un general secretary has said
so code red from donica vicki what's
your thoughts on this it's that 50 50
chance are you worried that we could tip
the scale and it could go higher
of course i think the scientists here
you know have something to tell us and
if the met office is looking at what's
likely to happen then we've got to take
out that very very seriously and it is
true that what is happening right now is
that if anything we are reversing a
little bit the progress that had been
made because of the impact of the war in
the ukraine and we're seeing what's
going on in europe where a number of
things
are now being abandoned
particularly for example in some
countries the surcharge for renewable
energy which the electricity bills that
households get
include so we've seen cuts in vit fuel
and so on so
and of course a real concern about
whether where the gas and the oil is
going to come from so everyone is
trying to find different sources
where that fossil fuel can come from so
yes of course there is some renewed
emphasis also on
uh finding alternatives and a lot more
green alternatives but it takes time
and i suspect that within five years
we're going to be wondering what more
needs to be done in terms of technology
in particular to get us over this hump
and i think it is going to be a serious
problem and i don't think the policies
we have a president are going to get
there and i'm afraid i agree really that
um it is a serious serious issue i'm
afraid you know whatever
wherever you're looking at it from uh it
is actually pretty worrying and i don't
think policies are present are there to
address it so donica where does the
responsibility lie with government with
big businesses with us as individuals to
collectively do our bits
well i would argue first and foremost is
it's actually with the media the media
isn't communicating the corporate media
not so much obviously this program but
the corporate media are selling it are
selling an idea that we can continue
business as usual they're actually
calling um the protesters eco-terrorists
and they're refusing to call to account
the all corporations the banks and the
government they're actually fueling this
uh fossil fuel uh bonanza the reaction
by the united kingdom government to the
war in ukraine is unlike the european
union the european union says we must go
full speed ahead on green energy and
energy efficiency
the response by the uk government was we
must go full speed ahead with north sea
oil and gas and consider fracking
and they're actually continuing the ban
on onshore
wind and doing nothing but solar the two
cheapest forms of renewable energy and
nothing on on energy efficiency today's
queen speed should have an energy
efficiency bill it reduces bills for
working people and reduces carbon
emissions and so really we have a
failure across our establishment whether
it's media government or corporations
and more importantly the banks so vicki
what do you think are the solutions here
because then there must be an answer
that we can do something to make a
difference
a huge investment i'm afraid is the only
answer i don't really agree that the
europeans are doing it right because
they themselves are as i was saying
going backwards and they're trying to
find other sources of fossil fuel
frankly for the time being uh yes of
course little bits are being done but i
think huge investment and cooperation is
absolutely essential and working a lot
more closely together that's the one
thing that the europeans are getting
right trying to buy gas for example all
together and also investing in the
future
in renewable energy and sharing it
between them much more than was the case
before but these things will take time
and i think it is the investment side
that matters hugely and i think given
that the world is slowing down and a lot
of money will not be coming in the way
that perhaps they had all anticipated i
fear that some of that investment is
just not going to materialize in the
time scale we want so donica we're
we're running out of time
are you do you feel hopeless when you
hear
uh the met office coming out with this
1.5
uh figure and we're looking at global
temperatures and and they're rising do
you think it will tip over the edge
well it's i i think as the your speaker
from india said there is no chance now
of avoiding 1.5 degrees we have to
accept that if it's going to if it could
happen the next five years it will
definitely happen within 10 years so
what we're now in in a desperate battle
not to avoid two and three degrees and
vicky is right about that finance is
crucial to this
and what we should what we should have
had today was a finance criminalization
fossil fuel
finance criminalization bill that would
make it illegal to pour hundreds of
billions of pounds into new fossil fuels
and that needs to be great by the uk the
european union and by the u.n instead in
october we must stop pouring money into
our destruction it's a crime against
humanity and the government needs to
wake up to that and stop um imprisoning
the desperate young people that are
saying to the government you must act to
save our lives
today as we sit here there's eight young
people sitting in our man in jail today
simply for standing in front of an oil
refinery with a placard calling for
action so it's interesting that you
should say that donnica because the
queen's speech today
didn't make any reference to climate
change as such but there was a focus
vicki wasn't there on protesters what
did you make of that
i think they're using that as an excuse
for a wider climb down on protests and i
think that's a bit of a worry
look sorry carry on quite interesting
where you were going with that yes well
yes and and that's a worry that's a more
general sort of political issue uh but
there is an argument that perhaps the
way in which these protests were done
maybe you know putting quite a lot of
people off um and of course disrupting
as they have done transport and some of
the facilities i mean that's been a
problem especially at a time when
there's been a shortage if you like and
concerns about the prices of of uh oil
at the pumps uh and that has affected
quite a lot of people's view of those
protests and yet i think there are
legitimate protests another question is
how you do them and i think the the the
what we've heard today
suggest that one will be very restricted
in the future as to what one can do
thank you very much donica and vicky for
joining us tonight on the show well
coming up in the next hour as the
government pledged a new crackdown on
illegal protests trevor phillips and his
guests will be discussing whether
climate activists are harming their own
calls that's on common ground at nine
o'clock well thanks so much for watching
we'll see
[Music]
hey